hello everyone and thank you everyone
for helping this channel reach 700,000
subscribers thank you for continuing to
watch the videos for continuing
subscribing even though I never really
asked you guys to do so and yeah as it's
customary on this channel whenever we
reach a certain milestone we will show a
nice game by the great Misha the
magician from Riga who is also a
protector of this channel as you can see
there well above my head and as we
didn't show any any thar games for when
the channel reached 600,000 subscribers
for this video you get a nice tile game
plus a puzzle but not just any puzzle a
puzzle pie by his fellow Latvian also
from Riga we saw this withers who was a
strong player Jasper himself but also a
prize-winning chess composer so before
we check out the game we are going to
check out his puzzle this is the puzzle
and you guys have to solve it
it's a white to move it won first prize
in the Colosseum ski tournament of 1970
and it really is just just a beauty if
you've seen it then you can just you
know rewind and go straight to the game
but if you haven't seen it you are
welcome to pause the video now and try
to solve it it's white the mate in six
moves it's a force maid so there is
nothing black and do about it and when I
say white mate in six that means white
mates in sex with best possible defense
from black with black defense poorly of
course white can mate sooner but we also
want to play the strongest moves for
black so there we have it either pause
the video or maybe just bring screen it
maybe you can want to share it with your
friends at the bar in the library when
they you know reopen so there you have
it
I will now mention the solution so for
those of you who are not interested in
hearing about the solution right now you
know just go straight to the game but
yeah so here white wins by playing and
not nothing other than Bishop to h4 and
this is the point with Bishop to h4 the
point is you want to play Bishop
captures in g3 King ghost f6 and E 5
will deliver mate but we're gonna we're
gonna get to that later on for example
if you try something like g2 saying that
ok I just want to give some material and
then just my past points will win g1
Queen is coming there's nothing I can do
it's actually just
g3 checking f6 and d5 is checkmate since
the bishop covers this the night covers
these two squares this is covered by the
lights partnership and this by the pawn
so the black King has nowhere to go
so after this Bishop to h4 move black
has to prevent Bishop captures and g3 so
just work here and blacks passed pawns
are you know ready to win the game you
just have to avoid being checkmated but
now white goes Knights the e1 but to
understand nice to e1 we first have to
check what happens after Bishop to f6
check because this is the main theme of
this puzzle Bishop f6 check King
captures and now King F for preparing
'if I've to deliver checkmate because
the black King is again boxed in and if
I will now deliver mate however black
has the free move b3 and now the bishop
covers d5 squared there is no mate so
white takes care of this after Bishop to
h4 Ruby g2 preventing bishop g3 by
playing Knight to e2 and now we
understand why a nice day e1 we
understand why this is played because
you either want to remove the defender
of the g3 square so you can play Bishop
captures or you want to get this bishop
away so black will not have this free
move guarding d5 square so if of course
if bishop characters on e1 then this now
works in Bishop f6 checking characters I
can get 4 and now any move you play if I
will be checkmate now even this you
don't have time to bring the best robe a
key 5 is just checkmate so here after
this Knights the e1 move Black has to do
something black goes to Bishop to d1 and
now says you can have you can have my
rook however I'm still keeping this
Bishop here so I have the free move d3
and now white of course doesn't go for
the rook as you could imagine but white
has such a brilliant move here that
really makes this whole puzzle come
together
Knight the d3 trick and now you see the
point behind Knight to d3 the point is
that you want to prevent black from
having the freeing move D 3 so here
black has no other options he's in check
and he has no squares you have to
capture the night and now after captures
now there is no free move
d3 and now the theme of the puzzle comes
alive again
so Bishop f6 check
characters and King to f4 and now
whatever black places since you do not
have the free move d3 just wins the game
there are no checks there are no ways to
prolong the game f2 years who are
threatening f1 checked but now e 5 comes
and it is checkmate so a beautiful
puzzle composed by mr. varus here so you
can see that he is no no stranger to
great complications and he does enjoy
such things in a game but here he faces
none other than the magician from Riga
Mihal Thailand well one thing that's
important to mention is that this was
played in 1951 also in Riga and ty was
15 years old at the time this game was
played so without further ado let's
check it out and you know see why why
the magician's games are one of our
favorites so efore invaders replies with
exe goes for the fringe defense and - no
I did not choose this game just because
black plays the French we have d4 d5 and
Knight to c3 so just going for the main
line with Knight to f6 and Bishop to g5
now pinning the night preparing e5 and
the Bishop to e7 black is now ready to
move the knight if needed we have E 5
again just playing the main line night
f2 d7 and here Misha goes for h4 he
offers a pawn here but it's very
dangerous to accept this pawn especially
when you when you face a player like
Misha point is after the pawn is
captured white really gets a lot of
counter play here let's say night b5 you
go after the c7 pawn and after the Queen
retreats now Queen g4 and white just has
a lot of open lines and Bishop is coming
to d3 Knight to f3 you can Castle
queenside it's just a whole lot of
development for the price of one pawn
and it's it's well if you play the
French I'm sure you've you've you're no
stranger to this age for idea so here
Vader says I know about this I'm not
like a beginner or anything he goes a 6
now he prevents Knight to be 5 and next
he's probably ready to capture on g5 and
win that pawn so here
Misha trades on e7 with Bishop captures
Queen captures and now just f4
strengthening the center black replies
as black should we have c5
here and here usually there are a lot of
games in the database that reach this
position Knight to f3 is the most common
move here but Misha goes night that e to
and it is as of mu9 that this position
has never been reached again and for
good reasons as there really is no point
in in placing the night Stewie - I bet
me shot the attacker that he is he's
probably either expecting this capture
so he can recapture it then it doesn't
really matter or maybe he wants to get
the night - Jeep to replay f5 have some
support for f5 and so on so black
continues playing normal moves knight c6
just developing and Queen to d2
we have b5 errors and now Knight to d1
either preparing to move at this point
to c3 to add more support to the center
or just going Knights to e3 and from
there you also have support for f5 the
knife can also come to g4 and so on so C
captures on d4 and now tonight
characters on d4 and Misha red his
opponent well he knew he was gonna
capture so probably the night was fine
leader on un'ytu or on f3 Knight
captures and e3 we have Queen captures
on d3 and now Bishop to b7 and now this
Bishop the b7 kind of becomes the theme
of this game as well this Bishop is is
just a terrible Bishop and Misha will
show just how terrible the bishop is he
goes Knights to III and okay Queen to c5
immediately offering a queen trade and
Misha calmly plays c3 offering a queen
trade but that's the thing if you trade
Queens here then this Bishop remains a
bad Bishop for the rest of the game and
without Queens on the board you don't
have all that all that many things you
can do it the night also doesn't have
all that many ways of entering the game
if b6 b3 just again locks the knight out
of the game so it's not not a pleasant
position for black to place so black
decides okay we're gonna keep the
Queen's on the board we have looked the
c8 and Misha just continues developing
the Bishop to e2 we have castles by
black and castles by white now again the
bishop and the Knight aren't really
doing all that much the rooks aren't
very useful for the moment so rook to e8
and now h5 just wants to open up some
lines we have Queen back the
seven and now rook to f3 so blac decided
he he doesn't want to trade Queens just
yet but now white gets the opportunity
to mount an attack so rook f3 the rook
is coming to g3 and he wants to create
some threats against the black king so
Knight back to b8 preparing knight c6 to
kick away the Queen and now rook the g3
just adding more pressure to the black
king knight c6 attacks the Queen and
Queen to d2 now and here black needs to
find an active move order although there
aren't all that many active moves for
example if Queen h4 seems like a very
active move attacks the rook attacks the
f4 pawn
however rook g4 just keeps the Queen
away and there's not much for black to
do we just have to go back and white
continues mounting the attack or a rook
everyone look every rogue g3 and so on
and of course if you capture then just
rook captures wins the Queen there's
also that
so here Vader's decided to go f5 he said
okay either your attack is is done for
or you have to capture each captures on
f6 I'll pass on and then I get some open
lines as well and Mishra says okay no
problem I will captors and he captures
on f6 Queen captures now black does have
some some free squares if he can get his
hooks into the game maybe get some pawns
movie and pulling pawn moves in and free
up this bishop then his position does
come alive however Knight to g4 attacks
the Queen here and now you have to be
careful if you play something like Queen
f7 just ninety-six share pics of the
Queen due to the pin here so Queen to e7
and now comes Bishop to d3 and now Misha
introduces another attacker into the
game the plan is Bishop come comes back
to C - maybe Queen d3 maybe you can
capture on H 6 7 and so on so rook to f8
now putting pressure on the pawn here
also maybe you can you can bring the
Queen intervene via Queen the c5 check
at some point so better back to c2 by
mission of preparing this maneuver and
now Queen to c5 with check we have team
to h2 and now Queen to c4 going after
the pawn here as it's now attacked by
the Queen and by the rook however here
you have a very special Tom move
and feel free to pause the video here
and try to find it while I'll give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and spotting the towel move that starts
the Avalanche that will will well make
this game famous and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's f5 and now with f5
well you just bust open the position
completely you open up the g5 square for
your Queen to enter and best of all is
that after characters and characters we
just see that it is impossible to
capture the bishop because if captors
Knight h6 check the King the the G point
is pinned you can just win win a rope
here so it's not really not really a
problem so here after this Bishop
captures an f5 rook CT 8 now the other
rook joins the attack but now Queen to
g5 and now well you can see that things
are becoming very unpleasant for black
and when you have four pieces like this
well three pieces in a queen in front of
the black king and the player with the
white pieces is the magician then you
know well the fireworks are about to
start so rook to e7 adding another
defender here preparing rook to f7 to
add more defense to the pond but now h6
preparing to open up at the position and
now you could play g6 but you of course
know that bishop characters is just
coming there's no point in even playing
that so rook F to f7 adding another up
to the defense of the seventh rank but
now now Misha starts throwing pieces at
blacks so just rook to e1 offering a
full rook here but of course the rook
cannot be captured if the rook is
captured then you get a knight f6 check
King h8 and now the amazing Queen
captures and g7 just awesome stop rook
captures and Age characters will be
checkmate
as the night covers these two squares
and the ponies of course guarded by the
rook so a beautiful pawn checkmate
and the rook is off limits so Queen back
to c5 adding another defender to the
rook but now neasha just goes Bishop to
e6 and it's it's quite a beautiful move
it just pins the rook on f7 and if you
play a weird move let's say Queen b6 if
you don't accept the sacrifice then
Queen g7 is made
now the rook is pinned so really really
crazy stuff so here you don't have any
option but to capture the bishop so rook
captures was played but now again rook
captures on e6 and now we have Queen to
f8 adding more defense that the g7 pawn
however here black is completely lost
feel free to pause the video one more
time and finish the game while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding any move that
wins because there are so many Misha
played rook to e8 and it was in this
position that we saw this velders to
resign the game as there is nothing more
to be done here we are going to show
another line because it's also just
beautiful and I know you guys also want
to keep enjoying the show but yeah here
we just resigned because you lose the
Queen and if you captured the rook it's
not much better just Knight f6 check
again wins the Queen or you capture the
night and then it's checkmate so amazing
stuff but there's another line instead
of rook to e8 that's also beautiful and
it features a queen sacrificed oh of
course we will show it it's H characters
on g7 and now of course it's just game
over rook characters here and now Knight
the h6 check King to h8 only move and
now again Queen captures and g7 with
check giving up a Queen Queen captures
with check not with check but just
captures now comes rook to e8 with Czech
Queen has the block and now of course 92
f7 a beautiful smothered mate to ended
the game so there are so many
possibilities Misha went for rook to e8
but as it always is in in his games
there are so many possibilities and as
the quote above the board says you must
take your opponent into a deep dark
forest where 2+2 the does equals 5 and
the path leading out is only wide enough
for one and as it usually was it was
only wide enough for Misha so yeah rook
to e8 and vedras resigns and a beautiful
victory by the fifteen-year-old magician
from Riga sir that's the game I hope you
enjoyed it the game and the puzzle and
for the end of this vid
I have a nice photo I wish to show you
guys let me just load it up I've never
seen this photo I've seen it yesterday
people have started sharing it on
Twitter but here it is it's actually a
photo of Jeremy Stillman and Mischa from
1988 when they visited Disneyland so
there you have it
just you know I thought it was it was a
beautiful photo and that you guys would
also enjoy it so let's just finish the
video with that so once again I hope you
enjoyed it and thank you all again for
helping the channel grow you guys are
simply amazing and yeah unto unto 1800
and well we are getting close to that 1
million mark and the moment when we
finally reveal the meaning of a god
matter so yeah I would like to thank
pretty much Lauren Chuck Peter Vidmar
Troy seamers Bryce Foster and fiora Dali
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot to really appreciate it as usual
you can check - on my previous video
Sierra thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the chest full
masters checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day